USA hi leo hey Liam every point a kissy
[Music]
like this is everyone the dogs
everywhere I going crazy because they're
excited they wish they could get that
pizzas they smell the pepperoni
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
partnering up with us hello what's
enjoying your new car I love it so much
I love it so much like I love it it's
home pledge have you gotten the seat
sturdy yet you think nope no this
leather is high quality leather they
even said like geo was looking into
because she also got white interior she
was saying that they told her that if
even if you get some like blue jeans
staves or whatever you could easily wipe
it off like this is high quality
material I'm testing it out today I've
got blue jean jacket and blue jeans you
have to do that alright anyways today we
are headed over to Anton Christina's and
we're gonna go visit little lay yeah
having seen lay in forever
I know and then every time we see photos
of her she's just getting bigger and
bigger I'm like oh my god guys and we
need to come over we need to hang out
with you guys
we need a Celia I mean we want to see a
Christina too obviously but yeah Isaac's
not with us again it's a weekend you
guys know the drill he goes that's all
weekend so we're like hey instead of
being at home
without our baby let's go play with your
baby our 11 year old baby photos friends
its birthday cuz I said in the caption
like I can't call you in my baby boy
anymore
and then aunt was like yeah use your
baby man hope they're excited I like
your hair so baby right you are so you
can see it all fast
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right what should we expect with you
maybe for this year let me listen I
heard that like women that want to get
pregnant and stuff that they're just
hanging out with more babies somehow
that like unlock some
yeah we should come over more often you
gotta slow things down I know you guys
just forfeit yeah always working and
doing stuff
prepare for no sleep yeah it's so crazy
because with Isaac when he was a newborn
baby I was so enamored like I was just
so obsessed that I it was too bright
like crazy but I'm even like cuz I was
so in love with my new creation I would
stare and while you slept because you're
okay like try to get in your nads when
they're napping like so you could know
because I was just so like I was staring
at him the whole time water was sleeping
oh just like as I can tell looking at I
definitely don't see what she's got me
that's when I do work oh that's true
[Music]
[Laughter]
those kisses you
[Music]
[Laughter]
what would you do that's right
or trick please are you ready for that
then you can have not twin that's so
scary
that's so scary that's nothing for your
first one - I know it's like it's not
that twins yeah oh for sure I think I at
the moment the plan is to but not at the
same time obviously
something you want to prepare for let me
show you guys so you can see what it's
like to see also fake cries right now -
oh no is it
she's like antsy drag your butt always
don't work out girlfriend that's why
you're in such good shape so tiring
yeah that's really tiring that's the Lea
crawl across the way we can do next the
bear crawls away girl with the bear
crawl that's a burger no wasn't it the
one where there is a bear crawls I
thought it was like this yeah you should
try you should try the layer all day
very stoked it's cuz I'm trying to
remember when Bart would train me he
told me to a bear call and I felt like
it was that but yeah yours makes more
sense
did you turn on the air although no yeah
if you want one you gotta lay across you
work the obliques just like that yeah
demonstrate real quickly there we go
the master at work coach Leia
hey that's hard it's a good workout
right this rocks - what do you mean when
[Music]
little bear little bear
kiss kiss okay only two daddy or mommy
she was might even else I think new
she's like getting hungry or something
look you know you are very oh I'm
actually getting married to a girl me
too
I'm gonna dig in on that
she's wearing a piece of necklace like
oh yeah if we were to have a baby would
you want our baby to be bilingual worse
other language oh no I don't know cuz
well I would definitely want that I mean
I wanted that for Isaac too but he was
learning Spanish he talked a lot of
Spanish but then we ended up moving in
with you and we only spoke English and
then I can and I got nothing holy
blaming you on you because obviously
it's my fault - I could have still kept
it alive
I noticed or not he's not carrying
Spanish from me or and you and we talk
yeah and then and then the thing is that
he's dad's house so his dad's Peruvian
so
his mom only speaks Spanish but she does
know some English words and so ever
since he was a baby I would always tell
her like hey don't let him respond to
you in English like force him to respond
in Spanish but she just never enforced
that so I think understand Spanish
videos and never speak it so that's kind
of I feel like and then a lot of people
tell me like it's not too late you know
you can still learn but I'm like I don't
even remember Spanish a lot so I talked
to my family in Mexico and I struggle so
hard cuz I'm like oh my gosh I'm
forgetting all of my own phone Spanish
because I don't practice it at home at
all
would you guys kick player like
Cantonese Mandarin I mean I would like
to but I don't speak it well enough so
we'll probably have to put her to
Chinese wall but yeah I've offered a
beat by the who I want her to learn
other languages which language would you
put her into probably Cantonese Japanese
yeah very helpful yeah living in SoCal
like you should learn Spanish
what's not as bad like as if you would
be living in Miami cuz I here in Miami
it's you Iowa yeah you have to know
Spanish like for sure cuz everyone speak
Spanish like that's not that crazy here
but it would be really useful that's
true that sound like dang it Isaac
Spanish sometimes like they'll be days
I'm not picking up from school and I'm
like all right Isaac but I say it this
all in Spanish and I'm like all right
Isaac from here until we get home we're
just gonna talk to Spanish or used to be
during the time zone that we would take
him to the office and then
really long right so the whole right I'd
be talking in Spanish and he'll be like
he'll tell me like how do you say
visiting and tell me in English and then
I'll tell him how to say it in Spanish
and so he'll be trying to say that
smashes our conversation would never
progress just seems like always trying
to figure out how do you say yeah how
much did he say I hope he takes it in
high school yeah yeah Raji takes Chinese
a snake not be useful to either one man
just you know another like for the next
kid I'm thinking both of us we should
learn Mandarin cuz I don't know how to
speak Mandarin we both learn Mandarin
and then we can teach our kid as we
learn Mandarin Mandarin I think we need
a shared language other than English
there's no language that we both share
you should be learning Spanish like I
just said in this very moment Spanish is
very useful to know in socal so you
should be learning Spanish and then we
could be talking to our future kids
Spanish to what you're learning Spanish
doesn't necessarily have to be a whole
another language that neither of us know
know say
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]